dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IIFA here there
are many research projects about
teaching an AI to play video games well
we have seen some amazing results from
deep Minds deep cue learning algorithm
that performed on a superhuman level on
many games but faltered on others what
really made the difference is the
sparsity of rewards and the lack of
longer-term planning what this means is
that the more often we see the score
change on our screen
the faster we know how well we are doing
and change our strategy if needed for
instance if we make a mistake in atari
breakout we lose a life almost
immediately but in a strategy game a bad
decision may come back to haunt us up to
an hour after committing it so what can
we do to build an AI that can deal with
these cases so far we have talked about
extrinsic rewards that come from the
environment for instance our score in a
video game and most existing AIS are for
all intents and purposes extrinsic score
maximizing machines and this work is
about introducing an intrinsic reward by
endowing an AI with one of the most
human-like attributes curiosity but hold
on right there
how can a machine possibly become
curious
well curiosity is defined by whatever
mathematical definition we attach to it
in this work curiosity is defined as the
a eyes ability to predict the results of
its own actions this is big because it
gives the AI tools to preemptively start
learning skills that don't seem useful
now but might be useful in the future in
short this AI is driven to explore even
if it hasn't been told how well it is
doing it will naturally start exploring
levels in Super Mario even without
seeing the score and now comes the great
part this curiosity really teaches the
AI to learn new skills and when we drop
it into a new previously unseen level it
will perform much better than a non
curious one when playing Doom the
legendary first-person shooter game it
will also start exploring the level and
is able to rapidly solve heart
exploration tasks the comparisons reveal
that an AI infused with curiosity
performs significantly better on easier
tasks but the even cooler
part is that with curiosity we can
further increase the difficulty of the
games and the sparsity of the external
rewards and can expect the agent to do
well even when previous algorithms
failed this will be able to play much
harder games than previous works and
remember games are only used to
demonstrate the concept here this will
be able to do so much more love it
thanks for watching and for your
generous support now see you next time